et je ne retire aucun mot à part le mot
canard de ce que j'ai dit là parce que
je pense qu'il faut pourrir la vie des
non vaccinés je suis vraiment pas ce que
c'est vous qui nous pour essayer la vie
en fait aujourd'hui on vise alors on va
en parler qui rit parce que myriam est
là vous avez fait ce tweet sont acclamés
tranquillement en famille à la terrasse
d'un café parisien un homme s'approche
et me dit ce que vous nous avez dit vous
êtes un collabo le collabo d'un régional
taurian et myriam a réagi elle a mis en
même temps vous avez voulu leur envoyer
des brigades pour qu'ils se fassent
vacciner de force alors cessé de faire
la victime façon député la république en
marche la violence engendre la violence
et c'est vous qui l'avez déclenché alors
vous par exemple guillaume genton vous
êtes vous trouvez que vous cautionnez
les propos de myriam oui parce que est
ce que c'est normal de recevoir des
menaces non mais est ce que c'est normal
d'insulter des millions de français sur
un plateau c'est pas normal non plus et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui quand on est
médiatisé quand on est dans une émission
qui regardaient comme c'est votre cas
par des centaines de milliers de
téléspectateurs
il faut mesurer l'impact de ce qu'on dit
et je pense qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
pas votre tribune des gens qui ont
l'opinion de myriam par exemple qui ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer parce qu'on sait
qu'ils sont sous représentés dans les
médias et je comprends qu'il puisse mal
le prendre et qu'ils puissent à leur
tour avoir des mots très durs contre
vous donc moi je soutiens mes rêves je
suis d'accord avec elle voilà au miriam
alors thierry il dit pourrir la vie des
vestes et on vous pourrit la vie abba
super sauf que non mais j'aimerais qu'on
vienne sur cet échange ou là on va pas
je reviens justement sur cet échange
alors moi je vais pas au resto en quoi
je vous pourrez la vie enfin les
non-vaccinés vont pas au resto ne
peuvent plus faire d'activités en quoi
on vous pourrit votre vie en quoi on
vous pourriez vous dit par contre vous
vous faites des appels à la haine sans
cesse alors moi je joue en quoi les
non-vaccinés vous avez eu un cas d'une
personne qui est venu vous voir en quoi
les non vaccinés les gens dont le
défendent leur lit qui veulent défendre
mais moi aussi j'en ai moi aussi on
n'arrive pas de m'attaquer est alors en
quoi ce en quoi ces gens comme comme moi
comme moi qui n'ont même plus accès à
des choses simples de la vie courante
vous pourriez vous avez choisi et alors
là vous avez choisi de vous de vous
vacciner très bien vous êtes contents
vous allez au restaurant s'il n'y a pas
assez de gens vaccinés jaoui d'accord y
amasser alors faut quand même savoir
c'est notamment sur l'est pas et on ne
peut plus cool ici
population c'est quoi c'est pas excessif
des mécènes tu me salis myriam ce qui me
gêne myriam c'est que les gens comme
vous vous n'arrêtez pas de dire qu'on
vit dans une dictature sanitaires si on
était vraiment dans une dictature
mademoiselle vous serez elle majore vous
seriez soit en prison au mieux dans une
vraie dictature c'est ce que vous
aimeriez activement pour mieux une
police politique vous aurez éliminés
mais c'est moi aujourd'hui je ne peux
plus amené mes enfants dans des centres
aérés type disneyland un parc astérix
etc je ne peux plus rien faire avec mes
enfants je ne peux plus aller au resto
non je ne me vaccinerait pas pour je ne
vais pas sortir des chiffres puisque
vous me l'interdisait non non on n'est
pas dans le jeu mais est ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est ce que les cheminées
chiffres sur lesquels vous vous basez
pour dire ça sont complètement faux il
suffit juste de regarder les comment
s'appelle et rapport de la drees ou de
santé publique donc déjà d'une rencardez
vous là d'ssus vous êtes journaliste à
la base même si comme moi vous avez fait
de la presse people je pense que voilà
vous avez l'habitude de 2-2-2 vous
rencardé justo mais oui voilà vous avez
été à ici paris un magazine que je
dirige d'ailleurs et vous avez commencé
à voie centrale a battu nice voilà donc
je ne vois pas je ne comprends pas en
quoi nous qui ne pouvait plus rien faire
et qu avons fait ce choix et qui en plus
moi par exemple je fais beaucoup d'auto
test pour pas contaminer les gens